[Musique]
il y a deux semaines se tenait en chine
la conférence des nations unies sur la
biodiversité
elle s'est soldée par la déclaration de
kuhn ming dans laquelle les états sans
prendre de décision concrète s'engage à
négocier un cadre mondial pour protéger
la biodiversité d'ici 2030 tout un défi
parce que lorsqu'on tente de sauver des
espèces 11 buts souvent à des impératifs
économiques
le cas du chevalier cuivré un poisson de
la région de montréal en est un bon
exemple
aux vêtements votre toiture faux
médicaments la majorité des objets de
votre quotidien ont probablement
transité par le port de montréal
1,7 million de conteneurs arrive ici
chaque année chargée une marchandise
provenance du bout du monde
et l'apport actuel arrive bientôt à la
limite de sa capacité
la première phase du projet telle
qu'elle est prévue c'est jusqu'à la
pointe d'abord sur environ un kilomètre
ça va être
le quai d'accueil pour les bateaux pour
répondre aux besoins grandissants des
entreprises qui importent et exporte des
marchandises l'administration portuaire
de montréal apm veut prendre de
l'expansion ici à contrecoeur 40
kilomètres en aval de montréal
on prévoit la construction d'un quai
avec deux postes d'amarrage jusqu'à 156
navire pourrait y accoster chaque année
plus d'un million de conteneurs serez
transbordés toute la forêt qu'on voit le
littoral convoi va disparaître l'habitat
de chevalier cuivré les déserts big
senti le chevalier cuivré dont parle à
la branche eau est un poisson qu'on
retrouve uniquement au québec les
protégés par la loi sur les espèces en
péril
contrecoeur ou le port veut s'installer
et son dernier bastion
c'est un poisson qui fait environ 4 kg
un adulte 60 cm c'est un poisson qui a
une vraie cuivre et les gros écailles
alain branchereau et directeur de la
société pour la nature et les parcs ou
snap québec c'est un biologiste qui
travaille à la sauvegarde du chevalier
cuivré depuis plus de 30 ans la
particularité de ce poisson là c'est
vraiment lui tant que dans sa gorge qui
pour un poisson de cette taille de son
de la taille des molaires d'un humain
adulte est la raison pour laquelle un
appareil aussi complexe à s'agacer pour
boyer la côte et des mollusques qui
composent l'essentiel de son
alimentation
on s'est vraiment un fin gourmet il ne
mange que des mollusques ces mollusques
le chevalier cuivré les déniche dans les
herbiers qui pousse en bordure du fleuve
comme ceux qui affleure la surface de
l'eau ici dans la réserve nationale de
faune des îles de contrecoeur
juste en aval du site où le port
projette de construire son quai nous
avons demandé à deux plongeurs de filmer
sous l'eau dans l'espoir de capter des
images de chevalier cuivré ils sont
rentrés bredouilles il faut dire que la
mission était presque impossible
il resterait au total entre 500 et 1500
chevalier cuivré dans tout l'écosystème
du fleuve saint laurent
ce qui reste comme habitants pour le
chevalier cuivré c'est une fraction de
ce qu'ils avaient hyacinthe
[Musique]
autrefois on pouvait apercevoir le
chevalier cuivré du lac saint-louis
jusqu'au lac saint pierre et dans
quelques tributaire du fleuve et relever
les plus récents montrent que l'ère de
distribution de l'espèce est maintenant
concentré autour de contrecoeur et
lavaltrie le poisson fréquente aussi la
rivière richelieu où se trouvent les
deux seuls sites de reproduction connus
on peut pas se dire qu'à chaque
génération on va empiéter sur la moitié
de l'habitat qui reste au final ils vont
rester seulement à des débits
pourcentage porté mardi de skull
d'habitat
pour construire ces installations
l'autorité portuaire prévoit détruire
0,9 hectares d'herbes y est considérée
essentielle pour le chevalier cuivré
elle a déjà obtenu l'autorisation du
ministre fédéral de l'environnement
[Musique]
lui reste à obtenir un permis en vertu
de la loi sur les espèces en péril et de
la loi sur les pêches
c'est le travail de nathalie loupiez
conseillère en environnement pour
l'autorité portuaire de montréal
ça fait une dizaine d'années qu'on
travaille là dessus avait différents
experts biologiste on a réussi à bien
cibler l'endroit on a en plus éviter un
enfant il y en avait plus on le déplace
et on ajoute des mesures d'atténuation
au départ l'autorité portuaire voulait
construire ses installations juste à
côté d'un terminal de vrac existants
elle s'est ravisée dans le secteur qu'on
a choisi que plus à l'ouest à ce que je
parle de 0 29 hectares dernier cd et
remixons éparses donc son port danse
alors qu'à l'aise on avait des amis qui
étaient un peu plus dense
pour compenser la perte d'ebita la pm
complanté 1,8 hectare de nouveau aux
herbiers le double de la superficie
détruite
elle a identifié les endroits qu'elle
juge les plus propices des ondes ou le
fleuve est peu profond et où l'eau
s'écoule lentement on utilise la plante
naturelle qui vont pousser en serre et
par la suite à l'aide de plongeurs on va
directement
planté
[Musique]
danse leur aménager de nouveaux herbiers
dans le fleuve a jamais été tenté
souvent je dis c'est un peu comme quand
on parle dans notre jardin dans votre
cour arrière l'année suivante des fois
ça pue c'est sa peau poussé bin
déshabille pas un suivi qui va être fait
sur plusieurs années alain branche eau
est extrêmement sceptique quant au
succès de l'opération puis quand on dit
qu'on va compenser c'est facile à dire
et c'est facile à écrire mais dans les
faits on n'a pas de connaissances
scientifiques
aujourd'hui en 2021 pour nous guider
vers des aménagements qui vont qui
viendraient pleinement compenser une
destruction d'habitats il ya pas de
science derrière ça
[Musique]
au delà des herbiers qui seraient
détruits le biologiste s'inquiète des
habitats qui se trouve plus loin en aval
pour aménager un nouveau terminal
portuaire il faudrait draguer des
quantités considérables de sédiments au
fond du fleuve une partie de ces
sédiments pourrait dériver avec le
courant est allé en sable et les îles de
contrecoeur
l'autorité portuaire de montréal assure
que la quantité de sédiments remises en
suspension sera minime l'appel va aller
dans l'eau et à sa remontée évidemment
une pelle mécanique massa ça va bien il
monte il voit son sol dans l'eau on voit
pas questi sport donc c'est la remontée
d'appel qui peut être plus lent pour
permettre de ne pas avoir un gros plouf
d'auxerre et qui émet plus de matériaux
spatiaux la loi sur les espèces en péril
interdit de détruire l'habitat d'une
espèce menacée mais il y à quelques
exceptions pour obtenir un permis
l'autorité portuaire doit démontrer que
la destruction des herbiers ne mettra
pas en péril survie ou le rétablissement
du chevalier cuivré si la pm décroche ce
permis les opposants au projet prévoit
contester devant la cour jusqu'à
maintenant dans toutes les dents tous
les recours qu'on a pris en vertu de la
loi sur les espèces en péril on a une
moyenne de 100 % il ya on est convaincu
dans ce colloque que le droit est une
l'écriture de la loi sur les espèces en
péril nous donne raison
le biologiste voudrait que le port
regarde ailleurs pour prendre de
l'expansion
mieux encore que la pm renonce
entièrement à son projet faire
disparaître le chevalier cuivré demain
matin ça leur ait pas de conséquences
comme tel visible dans l'écosystème mais
on est dans une période en ce moment où
on est en fait de voir toutes les
espèces disparaître plusieurs espèces
différentes en fait dans l'ue discutent
de la biodiversité qui fonctionnement
les écosystèmes séquelles briques qu'on
va enlever qui va faire en sorte que
tout va s'effondrer on ne sait pas donc
il faut travailler leurs perspectives de
préserver l'ensemble des espèces